well i don't i don't have the knowledge
to give a responsible answer but since
but what but i would like to see i'd
like to see I'd like I should see very
heavy carbon taxes and I'd also like to
see larger government expenditures
devoted to a range of defensive measures
against catastrophe but I think Ashley
is kind of heresy but I think that I
merican people are undertaxed you know
we have very low tax rates relative to
most countries and I think too low i
think i think only government can deal
with these a catastrophic risks not that
the government had you has to do the
research raining but the resources
required i think for effective
protection against them requires a large
scale government government spending is
I think we've been to I think we've
skimped on government expenditures too
much now partly it's a diversion it's
the diversion of the Iraq which has been
so extraordinarily expensive but if we
were ever able to extricate ourselves
from Iraq which costs about a hundred
billion dollars a year i'd certainly
want that one hundred billion dollars to
be devoted to other national protection
and not giving back to